Google cars they are coming they are
gonna be self-driving they're not even
gonna have steering wheels so when the
car goes crazy you won't even have a
chance people let's look at some specs
from the upcoming Google car yeah so
they're gonna have some interesting
safety measures like a flexible
windscreen foam like material the
maximum speed for now 25 miles per hour
so you're not taking a cross-country
trip on this thing
there'll be button first start and pull
over an emergency stop in case 9 crazy
happens of course sensor is used for
self-driving so that they know that
they're not going to hit another one of
these Google cars or a regular car and
seating for two passengers we've also
got a little video tape of what the
Google car is going to look like there's
no steering wheel in there ok so
starting in 2015 Google is going to
start using these cars in states that
permit it four states right now allow
the testing of self-driving cars on
public roads California Nevada Florida
and Florida and Michigan so I guess the
first thing is would you trust these
vehicles this seems kind of crazy you're
putting a lot of faith in the machines
people have brought up before you know
what if your car gets hacked
what if someone over rides your
computers if even if you have a steering
wheel you're still pretty [ __ ] in this
situation right I need to break it to
you but yeah there's there's a few
things that aren't accounted for here
like what if you need to to wait for
your you know grandma to get out of the
car in the car or what do you if you
need to go find parking in a several
stories tall parking structure and it
doesn't read it like you know as being
more than one story tall or there's so
many little things and I feel like
aren't accounted for right
technologically you just are kind of
concerned a little I mean not not all
situations can be I don't think it's
ready yet you know like what if I need
to park off-road yeah I'd like we're
ready to go yeah you don't think humans
are ready she was ready like I mean I
know they did like studies five to ten
years ago at Stanford where they had
driverless cars and pee
we'll freaked out granted it's been some
time since then but still people are
really uncomfortable not being in
control particularly of a moving object
it's in our nature to want to be in
control of our feet and where we move it
makes no sense to be in a car
I think biologically our instincts tell
us absolutely not right so before we
fully get to the hacking and all the
evil things that the machines are going
to do to us I think that's an
interesting part of this that just
giving up the control I mean just that
just getting into this thing and having
faith that it's not gonna get hacked
into or just something crazy isn't gonna
happen or someone else that's driving
because obviously we're not gonna all
change over it want someone else that's
driving normally is gonna just smack
right into you anyway
you know like there's there's just a lot
of pieces here this is a good idea if
all the cars are automated because then
you know traffic would be cut down would
be cut down but when you're still
counting on half the time like other
people's ability to not crash into you
and kill you
it's not incredibly fortuitous there are
so many ethical concerns that like
involve having all automated cars too
though like for example you know there
could be a case where a crash is
inevitable if one car has three people
the other car has one person what should
the car do who should the car protection
to protect you as the like car owner or
should it couldn't communicate with the
other there are three people there save
those three lives and kill you like
there are also many questions what are
those laws called is there a phrase for
those laws that robots are gonna have to
abide by like from iRobot like that kind
of thing where they're gonna have to say
like oh there's three lives in this car
one just as you just said and they're
gonna have to make decisions I keep
making prime directive and I know that's
not it
yeah cuz that is Star Trek I have other
concerns about these cars when I was
watching this video I kept thinking
about this how did I get in this taxi
the door open
who want to go with that guy that guy's
freaky that's my point you're gonna have
these Johnny cabs and they're gonna be
freaking people out
that's from Total Recall of course one
of my favorite babies yeah it's so funny
you brought them because that helps in
the studies they've shown that if they
have like a little tiny robot a little
tiny robot in a driverless car people
are much more comfortable yes you do
I would trust r2d2 to control my vehicle
I don't know that I want Jonica but that
even is interesting because we still
want some level of human interaction
there which is why when they when they
wrote that scene they had the guy looks
sort of like but it's scary that was far
worse than having no one there okay so
let's just let's finish up with the with
this machine's idea that and the hacking
and all that kind of thing I mean if
this stuff is inevitable then shouldn't
we be fighting it anymore
shouldn't we be fighting it more you
know I mean we're all walking around
with these devices that can be hacked
into we're all we're gonna be in cars
that can be happy to do all this stuff
and it can already be hacked into cars
can't be hacked into now with OnStar and
all that well now is the time to be
forming legislation or some kind of
figuring out how what the order of this
is and how it should work and we should
understand how it all works so that
we're able to voice our opinions
effectively rather than just being like
oh okay yeah I'll take that you're
saying that our politicians should have
foresight into things that we know are
coming and they should take
understanding what you're saying that we
as the populace should understand
something and our politicians should
have foresight to deal with it I'm
saying knowledge equals good nerd alert
those crazy nerdy thoughts let's say you
want to bring us home on this I don't
reckon be as nerdy but I was thinking
about car ownership and how this could
potentially change that how we may no
longer own cars if it becomes really
cheap to just have a driverless car come
pick us up and like take us we don't
have to worry about insurance or gas or
somebody driving it might make sense and
that kind of excites me because I feel
like it'll lead to lower carbon
emissions all right all right we brought
this around to not necessarily the car
apocalypse so I kind of feel good